all right uh dak prescott starting
quarterback for the dallas cowboys and
we had an item of news yesterday big cat
if you watch the show and i have a
feeling you did not we were talking
about whether or not dak prescott would
participate in the virtual off-season
program that the cowboys will have given
the fact
that he's got a franchise tag that
applies to him he doesn't have a
long-term contract he wouldn't have
shown up for the real off-season program
if they had had one that began on april
6 and during the program i was able to
report he's not going to take part in
any of this stuff without his long-term
contract stephen jones the co of the
cowboys addressed the situation
on tuesday on 105.3 the fan in dallas
and stephen jones said of our report
that dak wouldn't participate i'm not
necessarily aware of that he certainly
was sent an ipad with the playbook on it
i know he certainly can participate for
every player it's voluntary in terms of
their participation in the virtual
meetings i'm not aware and haven't been
made aware as to what degree deck's
participation level would be look that's
a way to avoid the real issue here of
course it's voluntary if you're under
contract or if you're not under contract
it's all voluntary this is your starting
quarterback who has a franchise tag who
doesn't have a long-term deal and the
guy who is the leader of your team the
guy who is going to make the offense go
or not go is taking the position screw
you i'm not going to participate without
my long-term contract and look i don't
know what else i expected stephen jones
to say but he's avoided the broader
point here
dak would be involved he would volunteer
to participate if he had a contract that
he felt good about the cowboys continue
to drag their feet on that topic
it's also one of those situations that
given everything that's going on right
now and the fact that everyone is uh
doing you know remote work work from
home
it does feel a little more pronounced
that the off-season program is simply
opening up an ipad and participating
that way and dak almost like in a weird
way mike i feel like dak has added
leverage here because the barrier to
participate is so low you don't have to
leave the comfort of your own home and
he's still going to sit out the off
season workouts and the
uh you know
en entire deal that they have for the
cowboys and basically make it be like
hey listen i'm not doing any of this
even though
it's so easy for me to log in so he's
really kind of showing them we're not
doing any of this stuff
until i get a new deal because usually
when someone doesn't show up for otas
it's not really a story because it
happens all the time when a guy's trying
to hold out on his contract but when
someone doesn't show up to their like 11
a.m zoom call it feels a little bit more
hey we really need to get something done
because i'm not even doing that
you rarely have a starting quarterback
who doesn't participate in otas even
when kirk cousins was tagged consecutive
years by washington he signed the tender
and was there because from his
perspective and he's probably right he
needed all the work he could get from
dak's perspective he's withholding
services at a time when mike mccarthy
new head coach would i hear jordan would
very much like to have
dak prescott involved and big cat look i
i'm i believe that
that dak prescott should do everything
in his power to get the cowboys to give
him the contract he wants the cowboys
are using everything that that they have
by way of their rights under the cba to
restrict that prescott dak prescott
should use every weapon he has available
but i think it can be a more delicate pr
situation from the standpoint of how the
fans react when all he's got to do is
turn on the ipad and what else is he
doing so i think there's a little bit of
extra risk there if you do take the
position screw you i'm not going to
participate
yeah i mean
i don't think any of these guys can make
a decision based on what the fans are
going to think because from a fan's
perspective we always think why aren't
you showing up to otas why aren't you
showing up to training camp come on
figure it out it's millions of dollars
you know usually you have the fan
perspective and it's simply like you
should be happy that you're getting paid
millions of dollars to play a game just
go ahead and sign so i don't ever take
the fans perspective into account here
when you're talking about a guy who's
trying to maximize his value at one
given point in time when you might he
may never be back at this point you know
how the nfl works dak prescott may never
be back at a a spot where he can
negotiate everything he has in front of
him and get millions and millions and
millions of dollars so i would never
begrudge anyone for trying to maximize
that and leverage every possible
situation they can but again you like
you said and like i said it definitely
seems different when it's a virtual ota
versus one where you actually have to
get in your car and drive to the
facility
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports